I have a documentary film that i do want
to recommend to you it is shocking
disturbing and endlessly fascinating as
are many things in the country of Saudi
Arabia the film is called Saudi Arabia
uncovered and it shows the true
brutality of what is happening in Saudi
Arabia including women beheaded in the
streets it has tons of undercover video
that was filmed at pretty significant
risk to the filmmakers it exposed as
much of the just inherent brutality and
corruption in retrograde nature of the
Saudi royal family there are scenes
where there are alleged robbers strung
up between cranes with young children
rushing to view lifeless bodies that are
on display in the kingdom and it's it's
everything that you would imagine it to
be if you've been paying any attention
at all to what's going on in Saudi
Arabia and uh it's it's of course one of
our close allies this is one of the
close allies of the United States shared
goals of stability with interest in
keeping oil prices both stable and uh
ideal uh for the sort of geopolitical
economic situation that is trying to be
maintained and i highly recommend
watching this although it it is
disturbing i am a big fan pat of north
korea documentaries as i mentioned many
times and increasingly i'm finding
myself just as fascinated with what goes
on in saudi arabia although it's often
even harder to get video of what goes on
in saudi arabia yeah this recommendation
to is quite timely because i guess a
billionaire prints from the country came
out with this very progressive position
that maybe women should be allowed to
drive after all maybe yeah right we've
been talking talking about that a little
and you know uh maybe not it's not
necessary to have mail permission for
everything women do maybe just for some
stuff that women want to do in society
uh saudi arabia uncovered it's on
netflix it's available on amazon
streaming as well and of course you can
see a list of all of my recommendations
including Saudi Arabia uncovered at
david pakman.com slash recommendations
remember that I am on Twitter
at d pakman and we are on reddit at
david pakman.com slash reddit that's our
EDD IT we will take a break what a show
we have for you today